is the Babylon 5 remake
reimagining at risk because fans don't
want it welcome to SRE your SciFi TV and
Movie
Channel they're giving you a chance to
change your mind ask
forgiveness
choose your next words will decide which
way this
goes I cannot help
you
[Music]
Jay Michael cinski the original creator
of Babylon 5 well over a year ago now
told us that he was writing a pilot for
the CW now I've told you since that has
been a little bit onof Warner Brothers
were not desperate to make something for
the CW but also the CW then changed
hands a company called nextstar took
over and they decided to invest in golf
and reality TV and it's seems very
unlikely that Babylon 5 will still be
going to the CW but Warner Brothers more
than happy to make it for somebody else
and I told you a few months ago actually
there were conversations with Amazon and
apple Amazon actually do look like
they're the Front Runners it just
depends whether this show would go on
free or on Prime now that is an
important distinction because it would
be a big difference in budget for me
though I could complete see a new
version of babon 5 G and free view I
don't know why it just seems to fit in
my head but anyway that's where we're at
at the moment and those conversations
have been going on but this is all on
pause while the strikes are on the
executives might chat about what they
want to do they might talk to streaming
services about who might want it but
nothing is getting green lit and nothing
is moving forward with JMS writing until
the strikes end now the writer strikes
have finished and I am here hearing that
the conversations have sort of started
again but the conversations have been
more do we want to do Babylon 5 at all
now the reason why basically Babylon 5
got this second wind was because the
original series showed on HBO and it did
really well we then got the animated
movie that actually did really well at
first but the numbers dropped off very
quickly but I am told that the initial
sales numbers were the top end of
expectations so they were very happy
with them but they've tailed off
dramatically and little bit more than uh
the people at Warner Brothers were
basically expecting it seems that the
fans bought the DVD but then that's it
the original series of Babylon 5 is now
about to get a Blu-ray release the first
time it's ever been released on Blu-ray
the expectations is that again the
initial numbers will be very healthy but
then they'll probably tail off in a
similar way this has all been sort of a
three or foure plan by HBO to sort of
build up towards a new series now HBO
and the people at Warner Brothers that
this news of a reimagining would be
wholeheartedly accepted by the fans
because JMS J mrozinski is writing and
creating they're not bringing in someone
new so this is not going to be at risk
of sort of like the rings of power
problem where a lot of fans think the
wrong people were brought in very early
on that actually the writing isn't great
and blah blah blah or how Star Trek has
divided fans with a lot of fans thinking
that Alex curtzman doesn't really get
Star Trek he doesn't like Star Trek it
seems so the whole thing with Star Trek
at the moment is that we have a very
divided fan base some fans love new trk
other fans hate
it Warner Brothers Are assumed they
could sidestep that whole problem and
sidestep being called woke by bringing
in the original Creator the problem is
it hasn't worked now I can tell you from
comments on my channel a lot of people
will say a reimagining a Babylon 5 I
don't want it that is going to be woke
but everyone says everything's going to
be woke sometimes so I I try to ignore
that to a point there was quite a lot of
religion and quite a lot of potic ICS in
Babylon 5 that some people would
probably today call a bit woke um I
think jmss did it so well that I think a
lot of people would ignore it but it
would probably upset some people a new
version of Babylon 5 will probably do
the same and people will yell woke at it
it's amazing though how many people have
left comments saying oh God please don't
do this it'll be hot mess it'll be woke
garbage and go woke go break broke even
though jmss is signed on and even though
he's going to be writing it the problem
is Warner Brothers have noticed they've
looked at how the fans have reacted to
the news that this was going to happen
and they're not sure it's a good idea
doing a Sci-Fi show even a relatively
lowbudget Sci-Fi show is going to be
probably 4 to $50
million that is a big investment still
and Warner Brothers because they owe so
much money for start are being very
careful about what they green light in
future and the division within the fan
base and unfortunately a lot of sci-fi
fans saying that this is going to be a
woke mess has made them nervous now I've
actually said to you this has been a bit
of a roller coaster ride already I was
actually told oh got a year ago that
this wasn't going to happen The Babylon
5 was just it was put on the back burner
the strikes then happened but then the
animated movie did really well they
looked at the numbers for Babylon 5 at
on HBO and did really well so that all
gave them a little bit more confidence
over Warner Brothers to push forward
with the project the problem is that
confidence is eroded during the strikes
those Executives have had way too much
time to sit around sitting on their
hands and to think about things and now
it looks like Babylon 5 is at once again
at risk now I don't know which way
they're going to go because at the end
of the day some be counter is going to
get involved they're going to do surveys
probably if they haven't already and
they will try to get something they call
metadata this is something I have had to
sort of really fish through with my
looking at
starget Amazon have been going through
exactly the same process with their
plans to reboot the Stargate franchise
they've been looking at metadata they've
been looking at fan reaction to leaks a
lot of leaks have come through Sidra
actually about leaks about about the new
project and if a new show was to be made
or a movie how would fans react now I
actually saw David blue um the guy that
played Eli in Stargate Universe talking
about this and he was actually talking
about how fans mustn't eat this project
from the inside out that we don't need
division within the Stargate fan base we
need everyone to actually get excited
about the new project and get behind the
new project Babylon 5 needs the same
thing it does not need people panicking
before it's even been announced that
it's going to be a woke pile of garbage
it doesn't need people saying I don't
want this the fans of babon 5 should
trust jmss in my opinion they should
trust him to do something that will
excite us again because he made a
classic sci-fi show Babylon 5 broke the
Sci-Fi mold and really did create the
road map that sci-fi has followed ever
since and I wonder can jmss do it again
I hope you
can but if the fans don't get behind it
and if the fans don't show that we're
excited about this it might not happen
so guys get into the comments and tell
me what you think do you see a division
within comments I mean look at the
comments on this video and tell me what
you think or go back and have a look at
a couple of my other Babylon 5 videos
and I think you'll see exactly what I
mean but do you actually think there is
a lot of division generally in sci-fi is
it actually people get angry about these
things or is it just a side effect of
the way social media works that people
actually enjoy getting angry about these
things probably more than they enjoy
getting happy about things at the end of
the day hating things is more
interesting maybe I don't know but you
get into the comments and tell me
exactly what you think why is there this
Division and if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us out
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com for citre
where most of our new videos appear
first and you get to see them without
the adverts also you can go to
c.co which is our dedicated website
where we do articles based on most of
our videos and we try to add a little
bit more detail and thought to it for
you to digest go check it out as always
please stay safe and I'll see you next
[Music]
time